نعم بالفعل مريم لكن دعيني ايضا اشير الى
هذا الخبر العاجل الذي ورد قبل قليل في
موقع صحيفه دعوت احرونوت ان مروحيه عسكريه
هبطت قبل قليل في ملعب لكره القدم بمحاذاه
مستشفى شعريه سادك في مدينه ال القدس
وكانت تقل جنودا مصابين وانها هبطت خلال
وجود مباراه لكره القدم هناك بمعنى ان
الوضع طارق واضطرت هذه المروحيه الى
الهبوط في هذا الملعب لكره القدم لتقل
جنودا مصابين من غزه يصلون الان الى
مستشفى شعريه سيدك في مدينه القدس
وبالعاده هذا يتكرر خلال النهار عده مرا
مرات لهذه المروحيات العسكريه التي تقل
الجنود المصابين من داخل قطاع غزه الى
مستشفيات مختلفه ابرزها مستشفى سوروكا في
مدينه بئر السبع وهي الاكبر والاقرب الى
منطقه غلاف غزه في بئر السبع في النقب
لوحده الانقاذ هذه المروحيات العسكريه هي
لوحده الانقاذ المعروفه ب 669 التابعه
لسلاح الجو الاسرائيلي وكما تسمعون معنا
القصف المدفعي مستمر بالاضافه الى الغارات
من الج ايضا منذ صباح هذا اليوم نرصدها من
هذه من هذا الموقع
وهي تستهدف مناطق في المناطق الشماليه
تحديدا لقطاع غزه منطقه بيت
حانون والى الغرب منها ايضا بيت لاهيه
والى الجنوب من هذه المناطق ايضا اطراف
مخيم جباليا تقصف هذه المناطق بشكل متواصل
منذ صباح هذا اليوم اصوات انفجارات عنيفه
وبين الحين والاخر ايضا نرى اطلاقا لقنابل
دخانيه وقنابل اناره بالعاده ايه تستخدم
للاشاره الى موقع جنود عاده على الارض في
الميدان للاشاره الى قوات اخرى سواء كان
للقوات ال ال الجويه او للقوات المدفعيه
خارج قطاع ايه غزه